en 2022 a Francia elegirá President poco
a poco se está dando a conocer la
composición del ajedrez político de esa
elección y a su vez las diferentes son
de oso pues están tratando de mostrar
una visión preliminar de lo que será la
disputa por el elipse por ahora Emmanuel
Macron oficializado su deseo de ser
candidato a su reelección pero lo que sí
se sabe es que es de su partido de
centro-derecha la República en marcha ya
se están buscando los fondos que hacen
falta para su campaña y también tratar
de encontrar un segundo aire después de
las derrotas en las pasadas elecciones
regionales y municipales en cuanto a los
demás aspirantes pues hay varias caras
conocidas como por ejemplo melón son del
partido de izquierda la Francia insumisa
así como ella ni grado de los verdes a
ambos ya dijeron 13 y en cuanto a la
extrema derecha pues esta vez viene con
una novedad de aquí en Marina podría ser
desbancada por el polemista Enrique y su
fuerte discurso en contra de la a cuatro
meses de los comicios pues todo parece
dibujarse entre 1 presidente que ha
gobernado de crisis en crisis con un
partido hay que le resta fuerza y una
oposición muy fragmentada
la campaña presidencial en Francia
enciende motores
adoptando un tono de presidente
candidato pero estaba eso no cuenta con
la fuerza de su partido político como
hace 5 años la República en marcha no ha
conseguido echar raíz perdiendo las
elecciones locales de estos últimos años
por parte del gobierno y del Presidente
de la República de
los territorios franceses
y ya ni grado de dos verdes con unas
palabras para todos aquellos que no se
sienten representados por la fuerza
política actual que creen en otro
discurso que se comprometen tanto en
Francia metropolitana como los
territorios de ultramar para defender el
planeta y su salud luchar contra las
discriminaciones y tomar las riendas en
su destino por su parte la derecha
tradicional ha puesto sus cartas por
primera vez en su historia a una mujer
vale gripe caes actual presidente de la
región Isla de Francia es la candidata
designada en las primarias del partido
los republicanos
es el punto de partida de una larga
marcha el punto donde todo comienza el
punto de partida de nuestra campaña
victoriosa porque lo sé es la audacia el
pañal h son las convicciones las
propuestas son las que llevan a ganar no
hay necesidad de ser ofensivo ni ser
provocador para ser consciente
palabras que hacen referencia al
antagonismo con la extrema derecha que
por primera vez tiene dos cabezas
visibles por un lado Marine Le Pen y por
otro Eric Zemmour un polemista mediático
con una retórica más extremas sobre el
Islam y la migración que la conocida
líder ultraderechista
en los últimos cinco años de
preocupaciones de los franceses han
cambiado en 2017 el desempleo era la
preocupación principal pero según varios
estudios para 2022 dos temas principales
serán la salud la lucha contra la
delincuencia uno de los temas
predilectos de la derecha y de la
extrema derecha así como la transición
ecológica sin embargo se espera que el
tema que va a acaparar todos los debates
será la economía mucho más que la
inmigración todo esto porque según el
45% de los franceses lo que va a
predominar el día que vayan a dar a su
voto pues será el poder adquisitivo y
precisamente en el país hay una
sensación generalizada de que durante
los años más joven pues la capacidad de
compra ha disminuido más si se tiene en
cuenta ahora con la reactivación después
de la pandemia y la inflación que está
en alza y que está golpeando el bolsillo
de los franceses